What?
Where am I?
I was just walking on a beach with Benedict
Cumberbatch,
Oh where were we?
Right.
DNews.
Hi there, Julia here for DNews.
Ever been lost in a daydream?
Ever had trouble separating imagination from
reality?
Yeah me too.
But there is a difference, and scientists
have discovered what it is.
Turns out when you are revelling on a beach
with Benedict Cumberbatch your brain is running
in the opposite direction of reality.
Literally.
Researchers from the University of Wisconsin
identified the neural pathways in which daydreams
and reality travel and they appear to be heading
in opposite directions.
The researchers tracked the electrical activity
of subjects, using EEG, or electroencephalography.
EEGS are noninvasive sensors placed on the
scalp, it looks like a sci-fi hair net.
Some subjects imagined riding a bike while
focusing on details, like shapes and colors,
and then watched silent nature videos.
The other subjects watched short videos and
then replayed them in their head.
What the scientists found was surprising.
Neural activity seemed to flow in specific
directions.
For those imagining scenes, the information
flowed from parietal lobe to the occipital
lobe.
From a higher–order region that synthesizes
information from the senses to a lower order
region, where the visual information is registered.
When taking in information from reality, the
information followed the reverse path, from
the occipital lobe “up” to the parietal
lobe.
How about people who seem to confuse reality
and daydreams?
They might be lacking a specific fold in the
brain, called the paracingulate sulcus, or
PCS.
Those with the fold have an easier time remembering
if something actually happened or if they
just imagined it.
They also perform better on memory tests.
The size of the PCS fold varies naturally
within people, some people just have larger
ones than others.
Unfortunately, the fold forms just before
birth so there’s not much you can do if
you don’t have one or if yours is small.
So where does imagination happen in the brain?
Imagination has been a tricky thing to pin
down.
Imagination and creativity used to be considered
the domain of the “so-called” right brain.
Which is now pretty much considered junk science.
Some scientists consider the hippocampus to
be a prime location for imagination.
It’s active in both imagining and remembering
images and events.
This close location
could be one of the reasons memory is so unreliable.
Yet researchers from Dartmouth University
have found out that the imagination isn’t
isolated to just one part of the brain.
12 regions across the brain seem to play a
part in imagining.
The so called mental playground is a large
cortical and subcortical network across the
brain.
It’s a place where you can visualize and
play around with images.
We can combine shapes or see scenarios which
may not even happen in real life.
Which makes sense, since imagining something
requires a lot of different processes.
It blends emotions, memory, thoughts, and
more to make-up something completely different.
These types of studies can help us understand
what makes us separate from other species.
What gives humans our imaginative edge?
And they could potentially lead to new tools
to find out what happens when we sleep and
dream.
Or could lead to a new cognitive neuroscientific
theory on consciousness.
What do you think?
Do you ever get lost in a daydream?
How contrary to reality is your imagination?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe here for more DNews every
day of the week.